today I learned where rats like to hang
out when they're in New York City and
which neighborhoods complain too much
and which two little about seeing fair
eroding visitors I'm Rotem Maya kugel
developer advocate join me as I upload
and then investigate the New York City
rodent inspection data set with bigquery
using the 311 table from the New York
City public data sets in bigquery we can
see a dramatic increase in complaints
about rats starting in 2013 we bucket
those reports in two locations we can
even create a heat map that shows us the
density of RAD sightings reported across
the city but that only tells us part of
the story to better understand the true
extent of rats in New York we need to
get more data New York City open data
project includes this table of routine
inspections across the five boroughs
we're going to load that data into
bigquery we'll start by downloading the
CSV file and while we're here let's grab
the data dictionary and import that into
Google sheets so we can use the schema
now we go back to bigquery select the
data set and press the plus symbol to
create a new table the smaller files up
to 10 megs you can upload it here
directly but our routing table is around
200 bags so instead we'll upload it to
Google Cloud Storage first you can also
import data from Google Drive but we'll
save that for another episode once we
have a location for our newly uploaded
rogan table csv will return to bigquery
and into that as well as providing a
name for a new table then it's just a
case of specifying the schema by adding
the name and type of each column will
use the data dictionary we import it
into Google sheets earlier as a guide
for the column names and to get the
corresponding data types we won't need
all of these columns for our analysis
but there's no cost for importing data
so we can happily pull it all in now and
enter in our table later in this table
it turns out that the timestamp format
used in the CSV file isn't compatible
with bigquery so we'll treat it as a
string for the initial import once the
import job is done we can review the new
table let's immediately use it as a
source for creating another table this
one will include only the columns we
need latitude/longitude thorough
inspection type and results in
convert the timestamp strings into real
time stamps once we save the results to
a new table we can delete the CSV file
from cloud storage and the larger
original import table be query charges
two cents per gig per month prorated
each second table we're going to use is
only 63 Meg's so we'd need to keep it
for almost eight months before we got
charged a full sent to using it with
that in mind we're all set to continue
our investigation we'll start by finding
the total number of inspections
conducted each year we can see it trends
similar to the 311 calls over the past
three years but with an odd bump in 2012
one of the advantages of using this new
table is that it also includes
inspection results we can see that about
75% at the time the initial inspection
actually passes now if we limit our
results for inspections that find active
rat signs we can see that the 2012 bump
corresponds to a significant increase in
inspections but not in rats that's not
the case in 2016 with increases across
the board but New York is a big city if
we examine the trends purpura looking
only two inspections that found active
rat signs we can see that while there
was an uptick across the board Manhattan
and Brooklyn are definitely catching up
to the Bronx crowned rat capital in 2011
we can continue our investigation by
using the locations of each specific
inspection to create heat maps to learn
which neighborhoods have the most rat
signs and what the current trend
suggests to the future of rats in New
York check out the blog post listed in
the description below to see where those
investigations lead bigquery includes a
range of public data sets including over
130 gigabytes of New York City data
including calls for the 311 municipal
complaints one as always your first
terabyte of data processing each month
is free go to bigquery today to import
your own data sets and share the results
with us using the today I learned with
bigquery hashtag and tune in each week
to learn more about bigquery with tips
and tricks subscribe to the Google Cloud
YouTube channel and follow our blog to
learn something new with bigquery
you